qui va croire ça vous inquiète ses
réactions pas du tout je comprends très
bien ce besoin de fermeté d'ailleurs je
le partage
parce que je pense qu'une république
démocratique n'a pas de sens si vous
voulez si elle déroule un tapis rouge à
ses ennemis mot rétablissement de la
peine capitale
attendez une république je répète une
république démocratique n'a pas de sens
et se renie si elle déroule un tapis
rouge à ses ennemis mortels donc je ne
céderai pas personnellement au chantage
de ce qu'ils nous disent comme certains
avocats justement de ces personnes qu'il
faudrait en quelque sorte reculer et à
baisser tous nos ponts levis face à
leurs réquisitions pour autant je pense
aussi et donc il faut penser je crois
les deux en même temps que la grandeur
des démocraties c'est précisément jusque
dans des situations exceptionnelles de
ne pas céder à la tentation de l'état
d'exception est donc d'appliquer les
règles de droit valide est normal entre
nous si on fait comme le président de la
république s'y engagent des enquêtes cas
par cas sur ces djihadistes sur leurs
familles sur la descendance
on aura une vision assez précise
notamment via les réseaux sociaux qu'ils
ont tous utilisé aussi par forfanterie
en disant regardez aujourd'hui j'ai fait
si j'ai fait ça à jaca ont été revus
donc ils sombrent traçable on aura une
vision assez précise de ce qu'ils ont
commis ou de ce qu'ils n'ont pas commis
et à partir de là on pourra appliquer
avec toute la sévérité qui est que
requiert cette situation exceptionnelle
les mesures de l'état de droit mais je
ne suis pas pour jeter par dessus bord
l'état de droit au nom d'on ne sait
quelle allait surenchère sécuritaire à
la mode